[Música]
e ela fala o lá eu nasci uma cidade
muito pequena no estado do pará numa
casa que não tinha energia elétrica não
tinha água encanada não tinha
encanamento hidráulico e quem nasceu
numa cidade com idh superior a 0.6 não
faz idéia do que é ter que ir ao
banheiro sem encanamento hidráulico
viver nesse cenário de sobrevivência
três eu me apaixonar pelo rádio muito
cedo porque na minha casa o rádio foi o
principal meio de comunicação a
televisão chegou um tempo depois mas eu
sempre amei o rádio e foi ouvindo aquele
rádio na época a primeira rádio que eu
ouvi que eu tenho lembrança foi à rádio
nacional da amazônia
eu era assim nessa época do ano os
monstros nome dessa cachoeira monstra
nessa época em que eu ouvia rádio
nacional da amazônia
eu lembro de uma mulher que falava na
rádio e e quando eu ouvi aquela mulher
eu achava aquilo máximo ouvir uma voz
feminina numa rádio em que só homens
falavam me fez acreditar que eu podia um
dia falar numa rádio
essa mulher se chamava tia heleninha
ela era uma contadora de histórias ela
contava histórias pra criançada todo dia
ea tia heleninha que me apresentou um
personagem que fez parte da minha
infância
o macaco simão
mal à criança hoje eu vou contar a
história do macaco simão ea velha uma
velha muito velha chamada referência em
célia tinha um lindo banon no fundo do
seu que alguém conhece faz a noitada da
velha outras bananas comigo pois o
marcados irmã global a todas que havia
um rádio faz isso
o rádio cria vínculos o rádio constrói a
realidade eo rádio fortalece a
imaginação
eu nunca vi a tia heleninha eu fui
pesquisar mas ela não tinha muita coisa
na internet eu só achei uma notícia que
ela tinha falecido mas não sei
exatamente como era o rosto dela de
verdade mas na minha cabeça eu sei
exatamente como ela era
depois da rádio nacional da amazônia
nessas voltas que a vida dá eu fui
trabalhar
eu fui visitar na verdade aos 12 anos
uma rádio a emi que inaugurou na minha
cidade a rádio tropical de paragominas
conjunto com a escola e sair de lá com
uma proposta de emprego pra trabalhar lá
foi o máximo
a minha avó permitiu que eu aceitasse
esse trabalho mesmo eu sendo tão novinha
com apenas 12 anos porque um pouquinho
tempo antes dessa visita da escola eu
confessei para ela que o meu sonho era
ser locutora e aí a minha avó fez uma
coisa que todo mundo faz
quando descobre que você é locutora é
você locutora fala igual a locutora
então e quando minha avó pediu para
falar igual locutora eu lembrei do que
eu tinha gravado que era um comercial
que passava nesta rádio era a única
mulher que falava nessa rádio tropical
ela fazia um comercial e eu achava o
máximo então eu aprendi a fazer aquele
comercial e eu ficava imitando os
11 as internações dela e aí eu falei
então tá
a mãe que a minha avó foi minha mãe e eu
vou eu vou te mostrar que eu posso ser
locutora e eu lembro que o comercial era
mais ou menos assim
desfrute momentos inesquecíveis e fica
nos braços de uma paixão ousado verdes
sofisticadas aconchegante e encantador é
a minha avó deu dois passos para trás
que é isso menina
o rádio ensina desde muito cedo com essa
experiência na rádio tropical eu aprendi
que para se fazer rádio
você precisa de três processos muito
importante
o primeiro é você ter um locutor com
estúdio todo aquele equipamento de
captação
depois você precisa ter um transmissor
para codificar essa mensagem impulsos
eletromagnéticos
depois você precisa de uma antena para
irradiar esse sinal e ele vai chegar lá
no rádio da sua casa
olhando isso essa foi a história do
rádio da minha história eu gostaria de
propor pra vocês três momentos do rádio
nesse primeiro centenário que nós
estamos prestes a completar 100 anos de
rádio
o primeiro momento foi a era de ouro do
rádio nos anos 30 e 40 com programas
econômicos de jornalismo como repórter
esso de programas de auditório como
agente ataque hoje às rádios tinham
esses auditórios de programas de
telenovela
a família se reunia na sala para ouvir a
nessa época aconteceu um fato muito
importante nos estados unidos na rádio
cib s
lá um jovem a um jovem ator com a
pretensão de ser diretor um dia de
cinema chamado orson wells
hoje a gente conhece muito bem e olha só
eu tinha um programa em que ele fazia
adaptação de livros
ele pegava o livro e adaptava como o
rádio teatro e ele decidiu fazer a
adaptação do livro a guerra dos mundos
que conta a invasão da terra
aí a invasão de alienígenas na terra a
gente tem um filme até que narra esse
livro que a guerra dos mundos
acho que muita gente já assistiu é
desculpa um filme recente e orson wells
fez aquela transmissão
no começo ele falou que era uma
transmissão ele fez a opção de usar
técnicas de jornalismo da época então
ele fez a programação e os jornalistas
entravam no a nando a invasão da terra
só que seis milhões de pessoas ouviram
aquela transmissão
muita gente ligou o rádio depois do
começo do programa e não estava
entendendo que é que era que aquilo era
o rádio teatro as pessoas ficaram
enlouquecidos
houve fuga em massa desespero gente
chorando no meio da rua
foi um horror era véspera do dia das
bruxas
foi chocante e aquele foi um momento em
que o mundo inteiro se deu conta da
força do rádio para levar a informação
da força do veículo rádio
essa década de 30 também deixou pra
gente muita coisa legal de produção
cultural no brasil a cultura aconteceu
dentro dos estúdios de rádio na década
de 30 e 40 e deixou preciosidades que
fazem parte do nosso imaginário
com essa música
orlando silva o meu coração pode cantar
a gente todo mundo saber porquê
totti ferir
[Música]
e também deixou músicas que representam
o brasil todo mundo como essa de ary
barroso
esses são só exemplos de astros do rádio
na década de 30 e 40
o segundo momento que eu gostaria de
colocar aqui durante que dentro desse
centenário do rádio é a chegada das
rádios fm no brasil na década de 80
vocês escutam falar do fmm a diferença é
a qualidade do áudio e quando o a rádio
fm chegou no brasil foi incrível porque
você podia ouvir música com qualidade de
cd no rádio
então muitas fm começaram a trabalhar
com muita programação musical dentro de
dentro da programação tocar muita música
isso me faz lembrar de quando eu fui
trabalhar na primeira rádio fm uma das
cinco melhores fm do brasil era muita
responsabilidade e eu tinha só uma hora
de programa dentro do meu programa tinha
que fazer a diferença para eu continuar
gaga conquistando meu espaço e ganhar
mais horas de programação então eu
caprichava e eu lembro bem que no
primeiro dia eu estava nervosa eu fui
fazer o programa e eu tinha um quadro
que chamado tradução isso era começo dos
anos 2000 ali final dos anos 90
o único jeito de você saber o que o
artista gringo estava falando na música
era um você fala inglês
2 você estuda inglês a professora de
ajuda 3
você ouve a tradução do meu programa e
eu traduzi uma música da maia carey
isaltino
[Música]
o não não eu não posso esquecer essa
noite nenê e o seu rosto chorada justo
mas eu acho que a história exatamente
assim vocês o rei mas eu vejo tristeza
na seu olhar e assim eu vejo tristeza
você olhar não
eu não posso mais viver se você é
[Música]
eu não posso
eu não posso mais droga
não eu não posso viver sem que você é
[Música]
é eu não posso mas dá eu não posso mais
dar eu não posso
o rádio ensina eu não me dei conta do
que eu estava falando e quando eu saí do
estúdio os locutores estavam rolando no
chão de tanto rir
eu aprendi que nunca mais eu podia fazer
tradução literal
analisando esses 100 anos de rádio
eu gostaria de propor agora olhar para
frente e ver o que vem
nesses próximos 100 anos e eu gostaria
de pedir neste momento licença a todos
os conceitos da indústria da comunicação
e até as legislações vigentes para poder
pensar diz rio disruptiva mente aqui eu
vou dividir também três pontos
o primeiro rádio o que rádio são
modificações eletromagnéticas que são
jogadas no espaço o que é a tv
são dados também codificado celetro
magnéticos que são jogados no espaço ou
seja é a mesma coisa
a diferença é que o rádio joga no espaço
os dados apenas de áudio ea tv de áudio
e vídeo
se a tecnologia permite que a gente
possa assistir rádio porque não um dia
não foi possível hoje pode ser o segundo
o pensamento segundo insight sobre esses
próximos 100 anos
a gente não pode mais ancorar a
programação de rádio em música porque o
rádio não é não tem mais a exclusividade
da exibição da música
já tivemos houve uma época em que o
rádio tinha hoje não tem mais
então a programação de rádio precisa de
uma
precisa de jornalismo precisa de
informação precisa de conteúdo precisa
de entretenimento
o rádio é incrível as pessoas adoram
ouvir rádio
o instituto cantar solto agora uma
pesquisa agora faz duas semanas
mostrando que no brasil são os dados de
rádio do ano que no brasil 83% da
população ouvir rádio
são 170 milhões de pessoas ouvindo rádio
quatro horas e meia em média por dia
as pessoas adoram ouvir rádio
a programação tem que levar muito mais
do que música
o terceiro insight e eu gostaria que os
professores os acadêmicos de comunicação
os gestores de rádio que estão ouvindo
esse toque os comunicadores de rádio
pensassem que a gente precisa de gente
excepcional à frente desse veículo
professores coloquem no mercado
acadêmicos excepcionais gestores de
rádio contratem profissionais
excepcionais
a gente vive um momento em que a
tecnologia é fundamental para usar a
tecnologia é fundamental que haja
inteligência
então é isso que eu vejo para os
próximos 100 anos do rádio
mais do que nunca é necessário haver
inteligência para fazer uso da
tecnologia
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]